qui a des gens des médias qui m'envoient
leur Dick pic c'est-à-dire quoi leur
photo de partie intime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y aurait un fils caché raconte-moi ça
alors ça c'est un grand moment aussi ça
bien en effet il s'appelle Simon
derender
déjà
été rajouté hein clairement né en 66 55
ans né en Angleterre en effet mais il a
grandi en Australie tant que alors on
l'a forcé voyez-vous à faire de la
chirurgie esthétique pour ne pas qu'il
ressemble trop au Prince au roi au
nouveau roi on rappelle simplement il
est né en 66 hein et Charles et Camilla
se fréquente depuis 71 mais c'est un
détail c'est un tout petit détail qui
fait que Oh là il est il continue à être
convaincu en effet que et bien qu'il va
griller la place en jour à William et
qu'il est le futur roi d'anglais
depuis plusieurs années c'est la mode à
la télévision de relancer d'anciens
formats une famille en or apprendre ou à
laisser et plus récemment la Star
Academy c'est que tout a commencé
à démission fait des records d'audience
et ont marqué toute une génération le
retour à l'écran n'est pas toujours
synonyme de succès mais est-ce qu'autre
c'est bien est-ce qu'on manque pas de
créativité
faut pas chercher midi à 14h pourquoi
ces émissions reviennent les jeunes se
détournent de la télévision ils sont sur
les plateformes il regarde la télévision
sur Youtube etc donc c'est un public de
plus en plus âgé qui regarde la
télévision et quelle est la phrase qui
est inscrite en gras sur tous les sur
tous les non les cuisines des personnes
âgées c'est c'était mieux avant donc on
leur donne que des choses qui existaient
dans le temps Excel jusqu'au truc est-ce
qu'on est pas un peu devenu est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas devenu un peu vieux con
dans la rue on reconnaît beaucoup alors
il y en a qui disent tiens c'est has
been alors je dis il vaut mieux être has
been comme elle va bien ça c'est tout
mais ouais
[Applaudissements]
et plusieurs moments de sa vie intime
refont surface dans un dans cette très
grande crainte que sa fille Manon tombe
à jour sur les photos érotiques qui
avaient futé normalement si vous en
souvenez c'était en 2000
pour faire court des photos d'elle assez
rôties ou même qui était porno
de son amoureux comme tout le monde le
fait où tout le monde l'a fait
pratiquement si papa les hypocrites tout
le monde a fait moi je l'ai fait juste
et c'est une photo privée pour son
amoureux
elle est complètement à poil on voit
longtemps elle se touche ah c'est ça
parce que moi tu me prends en photo à
poil comme ça bon c'est pas du tout mais
c'était pas pour nous non plus mais
c'est bon et elle dit dans son bouquin
ma salle antise aujourd'hui c'est que
Manon donc sa fille les voit quand elle
sera plus grande tout le reste la honte
humiliation la colère ça fait désormais
partie de mon histoire c'est vrai que
elle est comme une histoire compliquée
cette jeune fille non mais par contre à
des gens des médias qui m'envoient leur
Dick pic c'est-à-dire quoi leur photo de
partie intime il y a des stars qui
t'envoient leurs
animateurs des gens dans la politique je
reçois et je leur dis mais heureusement
que je suis cortiquée parce que je
pourrais balancer la photo alors moi je
pense aussi je pense que ça pourrait
m'abîmer moi aussi dans ma carrière le
fait de les de divergent en faites
attention pas du tout Agatha c'est pas
le sujet non mais c'est vrai genre
qui et bah sur Instagram déjà
une des grosses chaînes que tout le
monde connaît ben ouais il y en a il
t'envoie salut Benoît voici la table
non il parle un peu j'aime bien ce que
tu fais tu es drôle dans TPMP people tu
es drôle si c'est cool
est-ce que tu passerais à la maison
vendredi alors que le président russe
Vladimir Poutine fêtait ses 70 ans
Pierre Jean Chalençon a décidé de lui
souhaiter publiquement en partageant sur
son compte Instagram un photomontage à
sa gloire
[Musique]
un poste très mal perçu dans le contexte
actuel et l'ancien collectionneur
d'affaires concluent n'est pas à son
premier dérapage en mars 2021 en plein
confinement il est soupçonné d'organiser
des dîners privés clandestins dans les
salons du palais Vivienne mais c'est
jamais alors je souhaite l'anniversaire
aux gens que je connais j'ai jamais
souhaité l'adversaire à Monsieur Poutine
je connais pas ce monsieur par contre
je t'explique j'étais au festival de
Dinan avec justement Alain Fabien nous
montre sur les marches et je reçois sur
Tik Tok cette vidéo et j'ai trouvé cette
vidéo tellement drôle tellement décalée
parce que moi j'en ai rien à branlé de
ce type là mais ça m'a ça m'a fait rire
et judiciaire je l'arbalancer c'est tout
voilà j'ai honnêtement fait ça je vais
soutenu jean-luclette c'est encore un
beau feu d'arme tu avais même une pousse
un coup de gueule après avoir appris
qu'il a été placé en garde à vue alors
ça celle-là aussi c'est du ouais parce
que je l'adore Jean-Luc c'est
apparemment tu sais quoi il a vu les des
filles mais c'est un pote quoi c'est un
poteau
je pense que vous ne prenez quand même
un petit peu pour des imbéciles vous
savez très bien ce que vous faites vous
adorez le bad buzz vous savez vous le
faites en votre âme et conscience et je
pense que c'est
[Musique]
aurait déjà préparé minutieusement sa
succession c'est ma fille qui sera
l'exécutrice testamentaire elle le sait
même si elle n'aime pas trop qu'on en
parle ce sera elle et personne d'autre
sa fille c'est Anouchka Delon celle qui
aura la lourde tâche d'honorer les
dernières volontés de son père après sa
mort car on sait comme chez les Hallyday
chez les Delon tous les enfants ne sont
pas logés à la même enseigne très
fusionnel donc l'amour c'est l'amour on
est tactile donc on ne peut pas
déshériter par exemple dans le cas de
d'Alain Delon si on en parle il a
aujourd'hui trois enfants ça veut dire
que trois quarts de son patrimoine vont
obligatoirement théoriquement aller aux
enfants et un quart il peut en faire ce
qu'il veut d'accord l'offrir il peut
vous le donner à vous
comme la semaine dernière vous racontez
n'importe quoi en fait
je suis désolé mon ami c'est mon ami non
non mais je vous appréciais énormément
mais il est suisse Alain Delon c'est la
même
noire non mais c'est le même disposition
c'est 3 4 non j'ai la moitié de ma
famille pas du tout en fait en Suisse on
fait absolument ce qu'on veut donc là il
est naturalisé suisse depuis 84 je vous
le dis la loi française
succession et la même mademoiselle mais
maintenant vous pouvez vérifier pas du
tout tu sens que Roland aimerait ajouter
un
énorme
connard tu vas me saouler longtemps sur
le plateau non mais un avocat reste un
avocat tu vas me faire chier longtemps
exécuteur testamentaire c'est en fait il
va elle va respecter les volontés de son
père d'accord il y a des choses à donner
à certaines personnes
à quoi correspond cet héritage de Dana
Delon alors oui parce que déjà il y a
quelque chose qui à mon avis peut vous
intéresser sur lequel vous pouvez nous
éclairer c'est qu'il a commencé en fait
il a expliqué qu'il détestait les ventes
posthumes et il a accumulé 15 à 20
millions d'euros à peu près rien qu'en
collection et ça c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on sait pas également il a un
patrimoine énorme que ce soit en
immobilier en plein d'autres choses vous
êtes d'accord Sophie
en fait on trade Mouchka et les deux
frères Alain Fabien et Anthony tout a
commencé à ce moment là c'est à dire
qu'ils allaient même pas le voir
ensemble à l'hôpital tout est devenu
très très compliqué on lui a expliqué
tout ça après quand il a commencé à un
petit peu mieux d'accord là il a
commencé à prendre des dispositions
parce qu'il a bien vu justement qu'entre
ces trois enfants c'était extrêmement
compliqué